well this is a horrific story just
horrible and I could barely stand to
talk about it but I think I think we
need to talk about it last week a
nine-year-old girl named Maddy Whitsett
she was in the fourth grade and she
hanged herself committed suicide now her
parents have said that their daughter
came home from school that day this was
I believe last last Monday she came from
from school apparently in a fine mood
they were gonna go to chick-fil-a she
was excited about that running around
the house you know as you can imagine
you know if you have kids at home and
you tell them you're going out to eat
somewhere they get really excited about
that so she was running around the house
excited and then she went up to her room
and her mom went up a little bit later
to to get her and let her know it's time
to go to lunch and that's when she found
her daughter hanging in the closet now
of course you can't even begin to
contemplate the horror of a scene like
that I mean it's just it's just
unthinkable it's it's the worst it's the
worst thing it's the worst thing in the
world it's the worst thing that anyone
could ever experience and my heart aches
for her parents it's it's horrific well
when something like this happens of
course the obvious question is the
crucial question is why how you know and
to that end it turns out that Maddy was
was often bullied at school she had been
subjected apparently to an especially
vicious round of bullying on that
particular day according to her friends
so we know that bullying played a played
a role here was it was a factor and
there is no question that the kids can
be really vicious to each other
and sometimes it's hard for us as adults
sometimes to remember what it was like
to be a child and to be rejected by your
peers it's it's a very devastating thing
for kids it's hard for adults to deal
with - but especially for kids
because it's the kind of thing that a
child is just not equipped to deal with
I still remember the first time that my
daughter I remember the first time my
daughter was really kind of I guess
bullied by by someone by a girl that she
she knows a thought was a friend I guess
and I remember my daughter coming home
that day and she was really sad and she
was telling me about the way this girl
had treated her but what struck me is
that she was not only sad but she was
confused like she didn't understand why
somebody would treat her that way
you know she didn't understand cruelty
it just it just was a concept that was
new to her and so that's why kids have
oftentimes have so much trouble dealing
with these things because they don't
they're not cynical they don't have they
don't have the cynicism that you and I
have where when someone treats us with
someone's a jerk to us we're just like
well that's how people are you know
we're not surprised by it because we've
been jaded by the world and we're such
cynical people kids aren't like that
they they just they like everyone they
love everyone they expect everyone to
treat them that way and then when
someone doesn't they just can't they
don't know how to cope with it really so
when a child is subjected to this kind
of stuff incessantly over a long period
of time and then they go they take their
own lives obviously you can draw of a
very sad connection between those kinds
of things but her family suspects that
something else might have also played a
role ADHD medication
Maddie's stepfather says that she had
just recently that the the girl just
recently begun taking a new drug for
ADHD and one of the side effects listed
for the drug is suicidal thoughts so we
will never know for sure what was going
on inside Maddie's mind that day but her
parents don't think it's a coincidence
that she started taking a psychotropic
medication that causes suicidal thoughts
a few weeks before she
committed suicide and who could argue
with them and when you think about it in
intuitively it's just it's just the
suicide of a young child just seems
already like something that had to have
been caused by an outside force by a
foreign agent of some kind because
children that age shouldn't shouldn't
have the idea of suicide anywhere on
their radar they shouldn't even know
what it is right I mean it's a terrible
shock for anyone to commit suicide
suicide is a horrible tragic unnatural
thing for anyone at any age but a
nine-year-old how is that even possible
how is it even possible for a
nine-year-old to even think of that
you know people who are a little bit
older they'll they'll always say they'll
say well when I was a kid this kind of
stuff didn't happen it was you you
didn't have kids committing suicide when
I was younger that's if you talk to
someone who's 50 or 60 years old that's
what they'll tell you and they're on to
something okay they're not just making
that up in fact the statistics bear this
out that stories like Maddie's are much
more common now than they used to be
studies have consistently shown this
there was a study done recently that
shows that the number of children who
attempted or contemplated suicide has
doubled in just the past decade okay so
just in the last 10 years it's doubled
doubled think about that and we know
that this is a this is a multi-faceted
phenomenon it can't be blamed on any one
single factor so be it would be
oversimplifying in the extreme to say
that okay well here's this thing and
here's what causes it and that's it we
know that we can't do that but I think
we make a mistake when we just chalk it
up to bullying and then we barely even
consider what the other factors might be
because the fact is kids have kids have
always been bullied and as I said
bullying for children is really
difficult to deal with we know that
can we you know we don't want to
understate that or underestimate it but
we also know that bullying is has been
in the world since time immemorial yet
kids have not always committed suicide
at a rate like this because so that
means it's something else is clearly
going on here and we also know that as
the suicide rate among children has
increased exponentially so have the
number of children prescribed
psychiatric drugs they're currently over
I think it's over 7 million kids pushing
8 million kids right now who are on some
kind of psychotropic medication over
half of them are being treated for ADHD
now we know that correlation does not
prove causation so just because you've
got we know we have an increase in
psychotropic medication among kids a
exponential increase and then we also
have an exponential increase in suicide
so we know that these two things are
increasing together that doesn't prove
that the one causes the other but I do
think that there's enough correlation
here to at least make us wary about
dosing our kids with this stuff and the
drug companies obviously know that there
is a connection between suicide and and
the stuff that they're producing because
that's why they they list it as a side
effect in fact just a couple of years
ago health officials in Canada mandated
that that the the the the companies that
make ADHD medication they have to make
the suicide warnings clearer and
stronger so it's there is we know that
there's a connection and nobody can deny
it even the drug companies know it they
also know and studies have shown this as
well that that when you give psychiatric
medication to children it does leave a
lasting mark on the developing brains of
children now they might not want to talk
about this they might not want to admit
it but we know that now we don't know
exactly what those long-term effects are
or how they might manifest themselves or
how long the effects
last we don't there's a lot we don't
know and the the people who want to
defend these drugs they're gonna be
quick to say this they're gonna say well
you know you can't it's not a one-to-one
thing there's not a straightforward
connection that can be drawn between you
know suicide and these drugs or violent
behavior in the drug well that's true
but that's just because we don't we
don't have all the information there's a
pediatric psychologist named Ronald
Brown and here's how he put it he said
there's more there is more use of
psychotropic medication with children
than there is research data on it let me
read that again there's no there is more
use of psychotropic medication with
children then there is research data on
it so our the the prescribing of these
drugs has way outpaced
the information and the data we have
about how these drugs might affect our
kids that's that is that's a problem and
I would think that the lack of
information the lack of data rather than
that giving us a reason to just say oh
we might as well just keep giving it to
kids that's a reason to pull back and to
slow down and to exercise extreme
caution before prescribing these
substances to children but that
apparently is not how the drug companies
and the medical establishment sees it so
they just keep churning out the pills
and they shove this stuff down the
throats of our children and they issue
these assurances that that it's all
perfectly safe safe how can you even say
that how can you tell me that it might
make a fourth grader consider suicide
but it's safe and how can you tell me
that it might make a child hallucinate
and it might alter her personality it
might make her violent it might make her
aggressive but it's safe and let's keep
something in mind here childhood suicide
is just one
of the awful and increasingly common
phenomena that could be linked to
psychiatric drugs another one that we
don't that we don't talk about enough
that mass shootings dozens of violent
attacks in schools and and school
shootings have been carried out by kids
who are on or withdrawing from
psychiatric drugs and not just kids the
Las Vegas shooter was on anxiety
medicine the Colorado theater shooter
was on antidepressants
the Charleston shooter was on
psychotropic drugs the Virginia Tech
shooter was on psychic psychotropic
drugs at least one of the the Columbine
shooters was on psychotropic drugs the
list goes on and on now can prescription
medication be solely blamed for any of
these attacks no of course not again
these this is a multi-faceted phenomenon
and and in any time it's you're dealing
with something like this when someone
does something as Extreme as carrying
out a shooting or committing suicide
there are always going to be multiple
factors that go into it but I don't
think it's incidental okay it is not
incidental that so many mass shooters
have been on psychotropic drugs I think
it's foolish
I think it's idiotic for us to say well
yeah you know that's just a coincidence
it's clearly not a coincidence just like
it's clearly not a coincidence
that Maddie Whitsett committed suicide
while taking a drug that might cause a
child to contemplate suicide now I think
what we have to realize here is that
drug companies and doctors are playing
on a field that they don't really
understand and they are making
determinations that they really don't
have the authority or the ability to
make so what I mean is in the case of
ADHD okay what they've said is that kids
who behave a certain way and who think
a certain way and who are a certain way
must be disordered okay so what they're
saying in other words is that a child
they're looking at an ADHD child and
they're saying well that child shouldn't
be that way that that is not how a child
should be okay but that's that's my
problem you see that that's my point and
that's been my point with ADHD for years
now I'm not saying that ADHD people
don't exist we clearly know they exist
so anytime we have this conversation and
someone said well you haven't met my son
my son is bouncing off the walls he's
running around are you saying that my
son doesn't exist no I know that your
son exists like I'm not denying the
existence of your son or my own son by
the way who's exactly the same way just
bursting with energy running around
can't stop talking can't stop moving
that's exactly how my son is I have no
doubt whatsoever in my mind that if I
took my child to with my son to a doctor
and said doc does he have ADHD they
would say yes absolutely but I'm not
gonna take my kid to a doctor and ask
that question because yes I know that
these kinds of behaviors exist but the
label it's the it is the decision to
label it a disorder okay that is what is
man-made
that's invented that is subjective who
decided okay we know that there are
energetic kids who can't focus they talk
they run around fine okay who decided
that that's wrong why did we decide that
kids aren't supposed to be that way how
did we decide that that's in a disorder
that is disordered behavior that's what
I'm saying is completely subjective we
we made that up we have just declared
that these kinds of people are sick
because they don't gel with the systems
that we have in place
that is not how a real medical diagnosis
is supposed to work
okay the diagnosis of cancer is not
subjective because it's not dependent on
anything else okay they they don't
diagnose cancer based on how much the
cancer interferes with what else you
whatever else you've got going on in
your life that they don't diagnose
cancer by by by looking at the ways that
it interferes with your schoolwork or
your you know or your home life or
whatever cancer is cancer but with ADHD
and with many other alleged mental
mental disorders we only consider it a
disorder because of the situational
problems that it causes so ADHD is not a
problem
at recess it's not a problem when a kids
on a playground it's not a problem with
the kids playing kickball it's also
oddly not a problem when a kid is
playing video games or sitting down to
watch TV I mean all these parents are
say that their kids can't sit still I've
yet to hear one parent tell me that a
kid can't sit still to play a video game
oddly enough every kid can manage that
and I've never heard a parent say that a
kid can't focus enough to play on the
playground no it's it's with particular
things that we want them to do they
struggle to do those things and then we
say oh well they must be disordered if
they can't manage to do this thing now
it's true that that some human behaviors
are pretty clearly disordered okay so
someone who hallucinates someone who has
delusions someone who suffers extreme
paranoia
obviously these are disordered behaviors
obviously this is a sign that something
isn't right inside the head but wait
what makes ADHD so absurd is that what
we're saying is well a child is supposed
to be energetic is supposed to be
fidgety is supposed to be talkative of
course a child is gonna have trouble
focusing of course a child's gonna get
bored
doing school we know all that but if if
he's too energetic and he's too fidgety
and he's too talkative and he has too
much trouble doing a school work then
it's a disorder so we've drawn this
completely arbitrary line and said that
normal childhood behavior exists on this
end of the on this side of the line an
abnormal disordered behavior is on this
side well who decided where the line is
we again we just made that up now when
it comes to delusional paranoia or
hallucinations okay there is no there is
no amount of hallucinating that's normal
any amount of hallucinate if you have
hallucinate it even a little bit that is
abnormal that is disordered and clearly
there's something wrong in your head if
you if you experience any level of
hallucinating whatsoever but with ADHD
we are taking normal behavior drawing an
arbitrary line and saying anything
beyond that line is disorder that again
is a determination that drug companies
and doctors are not equipped to make
this is like a philosophical decision
that they're making they're saying that
well a person this is how a person is
supposed to be and this is the exact
proportion of behaviors and here's the
level of each kind of personality that
they're supposed to have whoo wait do we
ever stop to ask where they're getting
any of that from no we don't we just go
along with it so they're making a
determination that they're not equipped
to make and as I said they are they are
play they are playing on a field that
they don't really understand and that
field is the human mind and I say the
human mind and not the brain because
because okay we know we have brains we
have these these physical things inside
our heads and we can look at those
things and study them and everything
else but
we know that the brain somehow generates
consciousness okay and consciousness is
what we call the mind now here's the
thing nobody actually understands how a
physical thing like a brain can generate
consciousness nobody understands that no
psychiatrists no doctor nobody working
at any drug company actually fully
understands how a brain can generate
consciousness this is one of the great
mysteries of life is one of the things
that people have been debating since the
beginning of time yet with mental
disorders doctors are trying to treat
disorders of consciousness okay not not
not diseases of the brain
now if ADHD was really a disease of the
brain we would just call it a brain
disease and there are things that we
call brain diseases dementia for
instance is a brain disease so if a if a
if a patient has dementia you can do a
scan of the brain you can look at their
brain and you can see it you can see
dementia happening in the brain and it's
very obvious it's something that the
brain is being physically destroyed
physically and unfortunately
irreversibly destroyed so that is a
brain disease but with something like
ADHD you can't really do that it's
called a mental disorder because we have
decided that the mind isn't functioning
how it's supposed to but we don't really
know how the brain relates to or causes
that malfunction we don't no matter what
anyone says we don't really know because
if we did know they would that they they
would be able to diagnose ADHD by doing
a brain scan they wouldn't need to give
you a personality survey they would need
to ask you questions about how you're
doing at school they could just look at
the brain and see it but they don't
diagnose it that way because they can't
because nobody really knows what the
connection is
so we have we have erroneously declared
that the mind isn't doing what it's
supposed to and then we have set out to
correct the mind even though we don't
really know what the mind is and that
what's that's what makes a side effect
like like suicidal thoughts so scary
how can a drug give somebody a thought
how can a drug a pill that you put into
your mouth cause you potentially to
think something and not just think
something but have a thought that you
want to end your own existence I mean
just just think about that these drug
companies are giving things to our kids
and telling us that yet it probably
won't happen it's rare but it could
cause your child to think that he wants
to end his existence
how can a drug do that they don't know
they really don't know yet they gave it
to our kids anyway I think you could you
could really make the argument that it
is never safe to to give something to a
child that might cause them to think
about suicide even if you tell me that
there's only a point zero zero zero one
percent chance the fact that the drug
has that ability potentially has that
power and the fact that we understand so
little about how it could even do that
that's where I think that's reason
enough to to as I said be extremely
cautious with this with with all of this
stuff there there might be in extreme
situations if some child needs a drug
like this I mean in a life-saving
situation where there's some going
something
going so wrong with a child that that
they need the drug to save their life
well then that's one thing but the fact
that we're being told give this stuff to
your kid so they can do their schoolwork
how is that worth the trade-off and you
know the thing is even if the drugs
don't cause suicidal thoughts and of
course the really scary thing is it's
also hard you can't really quantify that
so doctors might say yeah it could cause
suicide though it probably won't it's
very rare well how could they really
know how rare it is how do they know
exactly how many kids have had these
thoughts after taking these drugs again
they don't know no matter what they say
they have no way of knowing that how are
they supposed to know what thoughts are
going on inside the head of a kid well
the only way they know is if the kid
says it but sadly terribly as we know
with suicidal thoughts most of the time
people who had these thoughts don't say
it either because they were the kid they
don't really understand what the thought
is they are scared they're embarrassed
they're whatever they they don't bring
up they're not going to tell you so we
know that these drugs have that ability
we know it does happen we don't know how
often it happens we don't actually know
how rare it is nobody does because we
can't read someone's mind but even if
you take ADHD medicine even if it
doesn't cause suicidal thoughts either
way it's the whole idea is that it's
altering a child's personality so it's
just take my son as an example again a
child who certainly would qualify as
ADHD a very energetic running around
talking all this guy stuff well if I
give him a drug and
suddenly he's not acting that way
anymore well that's a change in
personality and water also means because
right now my son runs around that's all
that because he wants to because that's
how he wants to express himself so if
you give him a drug and he stops acting
that way that means he doesn't want to
act that way anymore so something has
happened in his head to Megha so that he
doesn't desire to be that way anymore
and to act that way but again that's
something with consciousness that
there's something something has been
altered in his consciousness to make it
so that he desires things differently
and he experiences the world differently
and he sees things differently it's not
it's so it's not a simple thing of oh it
just calms him down it's not that simple
we've clearly altered the way that his
mind works not just his brain his mind
and again nobody knows exactly how that
works or what the long-term effects
might be nobody knows and so I think I
think that the drug companies and many
doctors are being very cavalier about
this and although there's so much they
don't know and although there's a lot of
information that they do know that
should be concerning and should cause
them to slow down but they don't you
know they just can continue on anyway
and more and more kids are put on these
drugs and so I think it's time that we
we start forcing them to answer some
tough questions and we start holding
them accountable and that's
thing to think about and I would also
ask that everyone pray for the family of
Maddy Whitsett
who are going through something that no
family should ever have to go through
thanks for watching everybody thanks for
listening Godspeed